Many people claim their "thing" is under assault
by culture.
But, yo, this might actually be true for science...
Hey friends who love science (or other people
who hate it), my name is Trace Dominguez,
and this is DNews, a science show.
Just FYI.
Cool.
Yes, I know science isn't literally under
attack.
Not really.
I mean, earlier this year, the former Secretary
of Justice of the UK did say, [quote] “people
in this country have had enough of experts.”
And at the time of this video, the possible
head of the EPA here in the US has called
climate change policy one of “many pretexts
for expanding government," and called global
warming "phony" and "not based in science…"
Plus, the Vice President-Elect called climate
change a "myth" and "a theory" and the President-Elect
said it's not caused by humans.
Though it might be a "hoax" perpetrated by
China... where humans live, so someone will
have to figure out how that vogues.
Maybe if we could call in some extra experts,
I'm sure the UK has some.
Meanwhile, according to multiple reviews of
the scientific literature, 97 percent of publishing
scientists who study it say climate change/global
warming is real, it's happening now, and we
need to act.
The sea levels are rising and the sixteen
warmest years since 1880 have all been in
the 18 years since 1998, with most of the
temperature increasing since 1970.
The science is settled.
There's a lot of evidence.
And yet, people don't believe it.
We sitting are in a metaphorical car sinking
in a river and debating how we got off the
road and whether cars float!
It doesn't matter!
We need to do something!
Why don't people believe evidence?
A 2015 study in the Annals of the American
Academy of Political and Social Science explores
that exact question!
But before we look at that study, let's go
a bit more broadly… a study in Public Opinion
Quarterly, points out politicizing something
like nuclear power at all "renders arguments
about the environmental benefits… invalid."
Even if there is a consensus!
Basically, when something is politicized,
we react emotionally, and stick to status-quo…
because change is scary.
So, knowing that, let's go back to this new
study about why we hate evidence so much.
Researchers created a model of human cognition
to see why people don't believe evidence,
even when it's right in front of them.
They believe essentially, we have a problem
separating our emotion from decisions.
Political opinions and ideologies are part
of those emotions.
Let's say I'm asking you about global warming...
according to their model and other research,
within 200 milliseconds you'd feel your "hot
cognition," basically prejudgement of the
topic!
You've already evaluated your feelings on
this topic and thus have an opinion.
And that hot cognition and your emotions are
then tainting how you feel about the evidence.
For example, if you've been told humans cause
climate change and you believe that climate
change equals regulation, and that regulation
is bad, then because of hot cognition, climate
change equals bad.
It only takes milliseconds for this to occur
-- and it's one of the first steps in forming
an opinion… but it's super important.
Because every memory, every thought and everything
after this can be tainted by the hot cognition
opinion.
The psychologists who published this paper,
think the reason you don't believe the evidence,
is because we prejudge everything with our
emotions.
And it's not just politics that can cause
it… sad music, attraction to the person
speaking, even the weather can affect your
true feelings on… well, everything.
But that's just one model of many.
Emotions do affect everything we do, but we
can fight the natural tendency to react emotionally
to evidence by THINKING.
The problem is that takes energy and effort.
Humans have a natural tendency, according
to early 20th century social psychologist
Kurt Lewin, to resist change -- thinking is
hard.
He says we like the status-quo (and our inherent
opinion) because we value the groups we belong
to now, change means inviting discomfort into
our social reality.
It's so much easier to say, I don't believe
you, you're challenging my status quo, my
default, my social reality, and even though
I've never read anything on what you're talking
about -- I feel that it's bad, and will fight
to not expend energy on this.
The moral of this story, as I see it, based
on this research, is people don't believe
in science because it requires we think, evaluate,
and re-evaluate.
Which is hard.
At times science does feel unnatural, it asks
us to question, be skeptical, and to debate
as objectively as possible -- all things we
don't naturally do well.
It's a skill we can learn, if cultivated,
and encouraged.
So, knowing this, if you want someone to believe
your evidence, don't appeal to their emotions,
appeal to their curiosity.
Avoid presenting evidence that will trigger
joy, anger, fear, or disgust -- instead, trigger
their thinking caps, their cognition…
And if I haven't convinced you of that, maybe
re-watch this video.
If you like thinking about how we think about
things, check out this video on our SeekerDaily
sister show about an ancient Greek dude who
says we all know nothing, even if we think
we know stuff.
Let us know why you don't believe the evidence
in the comments and please subscribe for more
DNews